no God no God please no no no no hey
send me that link to the monkey sex
video I'm going to forward it like it's
hot yes Lord it like it's hot for words
like it's hot then old school yes Toby I
need to talk to you in your office for
those 60 seconds
oh um literally two seconds toby is in
HR which technically means he works for
corporate so he's really not a part of
our family also he's divorced so he's
really not a part of his family
Toby's divorced he recently right you
and your wife and you have kids it's so
that was really messy
he slept one night in your car too oh
and another fun thing he at the end of
the night are going to give the cheque
to an actual group of Boy Scouts right
Toby we're gonna actually I think it was
appropriate to invite children since
it's you know if there's gambling and
alcohol and it's in our dangerous
warehouse and it's a school night and
you know who's just catering no no no no
is that enough
gone
why are you the way that you are
honestly every time I try to do
something fun or exciting you make it
not that way I hate so much about the
things that you choose to be in salary
get out no this is not a joke okay was
offensive and lame so double offensive
this is an environment of welcoming and
you should just get the hell out of here
okay let's go I'll let you in on a
little secret
I've been very much looking forward to
this moment very very much I I have been
steeped in anticipation
Toby has been cruisin for a bruisin for
12 years and I am now his cruise
director and my name is Captain bruising
Wow thanks Michael can I just say that
of all the idiots in all the idiot
villages in all the idiot worlds you
stand alone my friend you must feel
pretty good about yourself right now I
didn't put caprese salad in my drawing
let it go mm did you since when is it
illegal to put caprese salad anywhere
you know but the police could have been
out there you know catching real
criminals instead of here surgery's
kidding me are you kidding me that's
what you're worried about you're you're
worried about the cops time you think I
framed you and you're worried about the
taxpayer doc god
welcome back to your teacher face if I
had a gun with two bullets and I was in
a room with hitler bin Laden and Toby I
would shoot Toby twice see ya
[Music]
far and away the most expensive shot of
the movie but it was integral to the
story who brought him doughnuts
somebody got done this for my birthday
happy birthday you didn't know it was my
birthday I guess I forgot well I guess I
forgot to give you a dollar hmm
you know I I know a little bit about
what you're going through in a way that
was a kid my parents got divorced they
both wanted custody and they both passed
me to testify against the other one in
court so I don't know I don't want to
get divorced in the first place I love
them both so much maybe you still can't
make fun of people for race or gender or
sexual orientation it was who look who
let the lemonhead into the room you are
a waste of life and you should give up
is what I want to say but I won't
because that is why we are doing this
right now so Toby welcome to sensitivity
training for real Michael can't your
conversation wait till Monday I wanna go
home
well you don't even have anybody to go
home to Toby Toby why don't you open
your present no no no no no no this hey
hey hey hey this might not be what I
think that I don't even know is in there
because there are a lot of presents in
my car I don't know which is which
suck on this what the hell is that
Michael that's what do you mean Michael
that's not even my handwriting hey what
the hell is going on here who thought it
would be hysterical to give Toby a rock
for his going-away gift
you did no you made me wrap it I thought
it was over the line okay you know what
that is no what that is that is a psych
is the worst this the worst you are the
worst I ate looking at your face on a
smash it
do you know goodbye stranger Supertramp
yeah was early morning yesterday I was
up before the dawn and I really have
enjoyed my stay moving on
[Music]
[Music]
you